a new article adds to the growing
conversation about when older drivers
should hand over the keys more than 41
million drivers over the age of 65 are
on the roads today crash injuries sent
more than two hundred and ninety
thousand older adults to the emergency
room in 2016 now an article in the New
England Journal of Medicine argues
retirement from driving threatens one's
health and wellness vladimir duthiers of
our streaming network cbsn spoke to
older people about the independence that
driving represents Vlad good morning
good morning
this is often a touchy subject but it
became an international conversation
last month after Britain's 97 year old
Prince Philip caused a wreck when he was
behind the wheel he handed over his keys
for good and as we learned that's not an
easy thing to do 86 year old Joan
Mastriani has been driving around Albany
New York since the Eisenhower
administration when she was in her early
20s and while she still hits the road
with her 89 year old husband Anthony to
run simple errands it worries daughter
Cathy and her siblings wonder if mom
should lock the keys away you don't want
to wake to an accident happens in order
to make that decision you want to be
able to make that decision on your own
like we're not going that far but be
able to go the library and to church
into the grocery store as important
I don't think age as you can define it
as a certain age I think there are
people who are 40 years old this
shouldn't be driving and I you know and
I think that people that have good
reflexes and all the littler
revisionists but they could drive under
night
but deciding when to give up the keys is
a personal matter that experts say
should not be taken lightly when we get
a driver's license it's considered a big
part of becoming an adult so losing your
driver's license feels like the opposite
of that you cannot drive where you
cannot see at this class on Long Island
New York
senior citizens like Louis and Maurice
nipper are brushing up on their skills
you've heard the criticism that some
people have seniors driving past a
certain age what's your reaction when
you hear criticism like that seniors
come in all different sizes and packages
and have you know in abilities but I
don't think we are being trained
individually to recognize when we should
not be driving there are factors that
the educational course gives them a
refresher on the rules of the road
stopping for three seconds checking your
shoulder and keeping their eyes on the
road about certain things now Louis you
shouldn't be talking with your hands
when you drive there has always been in
this country a romantic notion of
driving the open road and the freedom
that it represents could taking away the
keys of someone who's older be in a way
detrimental to the health of some other
people
it's absolutely detrimental and that's
proven so it decreases people's ability
to get to work to have fulfilling social
lives older adults who are socially
isolated or have huge health risks it's
basically akin to smoking 15 cigarettes
a day
the master Yanni's don't want to give up
driving just yet I have a back-up plan
for when they put the car in park for
good well you want to do something to
get in the car go so but we have you
were around here and all we we have to
ultimately do that when I don't feel
safe I I guess I'll stop when it's time
to talk to a loved one about possibly
giving up their keys here are a few tips
check if permanent medical conditions
are preventing them from safely driving
such as dementia
have them take a driving test or enroll
them in a driver safety course for more
tips on making the transition you can
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com and one of the things Louis and
Marie told me it's humiliating when the
children that you first gave car keys
hand them over it's a difficult
conversation because most elderly people
still think that they were doing ok on
the road even when they're not yeah but
Marie told me driving the speed limit is
not a bad thing people say they drive
too slow they're driving the speed limit
it flashes thank you glad